march is credit education month and
having a good credit score is an
important tool you need to have to
qualify for renting an apartment buying
a house or car or maybe even qualifying
for another credit card sally taylor is
the vice president and general manager
of scores at fico good morning sally and
thank you so much for being with us
first of all tell us what is a fico
score for people who don't know and why
is it so important to have a good one
sure a fico score summarizes your credit
report into a three-digit number so
credit reports are maintained by the
three credit bureaus experian equifax
and transunion the fico score looks at
things like how long you've had credit
how much credit you have how much of
your available credit is being used and
if you've been paying on time
so the fico score helps lenders
determine how likely you are to repay a
loan and that in turn affects how much
you can borrow and how much it will cost
in the interest rate
and it seems like we can make timely
payments month after month after a month
but boy you missed that one payment
and all of a sudden your your credit
score takes a big hit what are some of
the other things that can hit your fico
score and how can people improve it
sure that's a great question and the
good news is that the fico score is
dynamic and it changes with your
behavior and it's also very relative
if you have a lot of historical credit
and you've been paying a long time one
missed payment isn't going to make a big
deal but if you have very little credit
it might make a little bit more of an
impact because you have less other
information but the important thing is
your fico score today doesn't have to be
your fico score tomorrow there are
several things that a consumer can do to
improve their fico scores one is stay up
on paying your bills pay them on time
pay your credit on time and apply only
for the credit that you need and
consumers should also actively monitor
their fico score because re research has
shown that consumers who frequently
check their fico score are more likely
to have a higher credit score
and how can you do that i think people
feel like if they're checking uh to get
their fico score or maybe get off their
credit report that that's going to hurt
them is that true
that's actually not true if the consumer
checks their credit reporter score it
has no impact on the score it's only
when you apply for credit that it might
have impact
so the first important thing in
monitoring your score is to make sure
it's a fico score this is a score that's
90 percent of lenders use and so if it
doesn't say fico score it's most likely
not a fico score there are several ways
that you can monitor over 200 financial
institutions give their customers free
access to the fico scores that they use
to manage accounts so many people
receive their fico scores through their
institutions on their monthly statements
or on their mobile banking app or web
portal you can also go to myfico.com to
monitor your score
okay and for people who don't really
have established credit how can fico
help them yeah that's a great question
the good news is that lenders want to
include new borrowers
but they're limited in in a sense
with someone who doesn't have any credit
history in it in their ability to assess
credit risk so to help address this
fico's led the way in the use of
alternative data and innovative credit
scoring techniques we've introduced
scores like fico score xd and the ultra
fico score they look at additional
information such as how you've paid your
telco or utility bills information from
your checking and savings account in
fact we can score ninety percent of
credit eligible consumers in the us
the other important thing is financial
education so we created score a better
future it's a financial education
program that works with nonprofits
nationwide it helps consumers understand
their credit and their overall financial
health our next virtual event will be
held this april and it's free
and you can go to
scoreabetterfuture.com for more
information
i think that's great information because
i think a lot of young college students
who maybe don't have credit cards or
they haven't signed the rent at least
yet and been making those payments to
establish credit
they're coming right out of college and
thinking oh my gosh i don't have a fico
score what am i going to do so it is
nice to know that there are ways and
that there is help out there for them
anything else that you'd like to add and
and maybe uh tell us what's the best
credit score and how do you get there
and boy the discipline it takes to keep
a good credit score because it's so
important
sure credit scores range from their 300s
to 8.50 so 850 would be the best but you
don't need the best to have good credit
anything in the upper 700s is great
credit and people who are in the 800s
have no problem getting all the credit
they need at the best terms
so i think that's really important you
know it's not really a matter of
perfection it's it's just a matter of
behaving responsibly with your debt
tried and true always pay your bills on
time and don't take on more credit than
you need
that's good to know i just have one
quick question sally and then and then
i'll let you go you know we're getting
those credit card offers constantly in
the mail and they say oh you've
pre-qualified for this great new credit
card what do we what should we do with
those what should we think about those
and if we're replying to them uh how are
they processing those applications sure
so when you reply to those they process
them as as though
yeah you applied for credit um so it's
not really any different there and the
way you consider that is not different
either right only apply for credit that
that you need
um you don't uh if you don't need the
credit don't don't don't don't get it
because
uh it's all about maintaining uh the
your your your balances in a way that
you can afford it
ah that's good to remember don't get any
more credit
if it's there it's so tempting to use it
right it doesn't necessarily mean we can
afford it
all right thank you so much sally we
appreciate it where can somebody go for
more information if they'd like to learn
maybe about that free workshop or other
important information sure for the free
workshop score a betterfuture.com
and for more information about your fico
score myfico.com
all right thanks so much it was a
pleasure appreciate all your great
valuable information have a good day